we have Michael knows one of our
favorite guests he's of course the host
of the Michael no shell no shell good
morning sir welcome good morning you'll
see you good to see we've been talking
all morning about how Democrats made
this solemn promise really the American
people we need to take the country back
from Donald Trump in the midterms and
we're going to do it by focusing on the
economy and focusing on health care and
we're gonna be all about decency and the
American Way what happened what happened
well it was a tough jobs number for them
to focus on the economy and the I have
to tell you this incoming
democrat-controlled Congress is the best
advertisement for Trump 2020 Donald
Trump he's not the most polite guy in
the world
Rashidah Talib saying we're going to
impeach the mother-effer it makes him
look polite by comparison this is no
small feat what sir Alexandria Cassio
Cortes calling for upwards of an eighty
two point seven percent tax rate for
some Americans makes Donald Trump look
moderate by comparison Donald Trump
thrives on adversaries he now has an
entire house full of them and it's this
optic choice the GOP Congress I'm sorry
to say was not passing very much
legislation so now at least Americans
can see the difference you've got one
part of the Congress being controlled by
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez the new face of
the Democrats then the the face of the
incoming Republicans who is it it's Dan
Crenshaw it's Jim Baird it's American
heroes who have sacrificed for their
country that's a juxtaposition and a
choice that I want Americans to see all
day long Michael we're gonna get to
Alexandria in a minute but some of the
legislation that Democrats are pushing
articles of impeachment presidential
candidates required to release tax
returns can't imagine who that's
targeting Moeller protection bill
abolishing the electoral college because
a lot of them are a bunch of sore losers
and they want to try to change a system
to into something where they can win so
what do you make of that I mean do the
American people see through that and
dude does the Democratic base of voters
are they getting angry looking at that
they certainly see through that it's all
bark and no bite you look at what issues
matter to Americans they care about
immigration
Donald Trump has played his hand
perfectly here on the government
shutdown they care about the economy the
jobs numbers that are coming out look
great and the stock market is reacting
to that they don't care about a
politician's tax returns
nobody cares at all and so fortunately
now you've got this one part of the
Congress you've got the House of
Representatives calling for all of these
crazy radical reforms sore-loser bills
because they can't convince voters to
give them the White House they can't
convince voters to give them the Senate
but then you've got the the presidency
who can rebut that who can fight against
that and you've and you've got the
Senate as a backstop so I don't think
you're gonna see impeachment anytime
soon you're just going to see more of
this reality TV show a political game
and unfortunately for the Democrats
Donald Trump is the master of reality TV
yeah well Michael one of your favorite
socialists she's not known for her
modesty she seemed to double down on
thinking highly of herself here she is
in an interview watch once you get to
like the tippy tops on your ten
millionth dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70% as you climb up this ladder
you should be contributing more the only
has ever been radicals that have changed
this country Abraham Lincoln made the
radical decision to sign the
Emancipation Proclamation
Franklin Delano Roosevelt made the
radical decision to embark on
establishing programs like Social
Security you know if that's what radical
means call me a radical Colorado she's
talking about Lincoln bringing Liberty
okay and now she's saying we want to
shackle you with taxes I mean she
doesn't even understand what you said
and don't you remember when Abraham
Lincoln instituted an 83 percent tax
rate though she I don't know maybe I
history is a little shaky yeah this is
all we could ask for you you now have
open socialists in the Congress and I'm
glad that we're having an honest
conversation I think for a long time
Democrats and the left tried to hide
their socialist tendencies at least now
it's coming out there do we think that
Americans want to work 83% of the time
for the government I don't think so
do we unfortunately history is not
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's strong suit
and so she's misrepresenting American
history she misrepresents her own
history too she pretends that she grew
up in the Bronx she didn't she grew up
in a very
affluent suburb of New York I know I
grew up in the town next to her and they
do this all the time socialists who come
out of privilege pretend to be working
class heroes to defend their ridiculous
policies Americans see right through
that well you you are in a bit of a
Twitter spat it might say recently with
her she tweeted this she said don't be
fooled by the plaques that we got I'm
still I'm still Alex from the Bronx
quippy you replied you trouble is that
she's not of course yeah you know I grew
up in the town right next door yes you
tweeted I you didn't grow up between two
worlds you grew up in Westchester then
lied about it then change your bio when
the lie was exposed I grew up in the low
affluent high diverse neighborhood town
spent many weekends in the Bronx the
difference I don't lie about my
upbringing to feign victimhood she
didn't like you pointing that out she
was very upset she was tweeting about it
for a whole day the reason I point this
out by the way is not just to pick on
Alexandria it's not because I don't like
her or something it's because one she
uses this lie this fake narrative of her
upbringing to excuse her blithe
ignorance she pretends to have not grown
up in privilege not had access to the
best schools she really did she should
know these things she should be able to
answer basic economic and historical
questions but also this is what
socialists always do they have to
pretend to be the working class heroes
they have to pretend that they're
speaking for the poor that they're
speaking for the oppressed
there's nothing oppressed about
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez or Elizabeth
Warren Brock Obama or Bernie Sanders and
socialism is not the way to fix poverty
it never has it has bred human misery it
has destroyed economies the way to live
hundreds of millions of people out of
poverty in just the last several decades
is capitalism it's free markets and
we're seeing the effects of that because
of this administration we look forward
to your next Twitter battle with Ocasio
Cortez